this must be uh i mean you got to
describe for me the feeling of being out
there having stephen colbert introduce
you guys to this crowd yeah yeah i mean
it was uh that was incredible and i was
i was intimidated you know you sat next
to a
you know he's really well vested in the
legendarium and so i really like the
things that he said in between the
panels and the introduction and it's
really great to see somebody who's just
so passionate about his work and so we
were very lucky just to get an
individual who cared so much but at the
same time he's stephen colbert yeah did
you feel a bit in his presence like oh
man i should have studied up actually on
my lore a bit more
uh
i mean i i reckon anybody would think
that with him you know um because he's
so i mean the great thing about tolkien
is that you know if you think one thing
somebody usually thinks something else
for a different reason because there's
so many different versions and
you know different different opinions
you can take and so it's like it's uh
that's why i love so much about his work
you know uh the language that tolkien
uses is so distinct is there a word a
phrase or a name that you just luxuriate
in that you love seeing yeah
yeah yeah
that's a pretty good one yeah i think
probably but there's like there's a
great moment in the show where he's sort
of blown away and i say el mendez
which i really like and all of those
beauty i mean you know
elven words are beautiful to say it
doesn't matter what it is so yeah
there's this countless ones i could give
you
now
obviously tons of people make uh
the original trilogy like a an annual
thing like they watch their christmas
they watch it they go back and re-uh
review it um is there anyone from the
cast that you would kind of go nuts to
know that they are a fan of your show
anyone in the cast anyone in the
original cast of the original trilogy
that you would like go nuts to know that
they would be a fan of your show oh
anyone everyone i i hope people i just
really hope people like it you know um
yeah i mean come on anyone um any one of
them any anyone of anyone
yeah i just really hope people enjoy it
um everybody's worked extremely hard on
it so yeah i'm hoping obviously when
you're in the middle of filming you're
that character you're creating that
world but were there ever moments you
kind of broke character and you're like
this kicks ass like people are going to
love this
and in the
in the moment no because you feel the
responsibility like you know like it's i
always took very seriously and take very
seriously the the the task that's been
given to me i love my character i know
that he's um
beloved you know and so i worked as hard
as i possibly could on this role at all
times and only afterwards did i think
you know that was really cool or if we
were brought in to see something that
was not a work day you know we were
brought in to see a set that we were
going to work on but we weren't working
on today then you had the opportunity to
be blown away by something you know but
if you allowed it to because of the
scale of it it would just
you'd never get anything done break down
every day yeah exactly yeah yeah
i'm so excited for the serious
congratulations
you